[Music]
last weekend more than 126 000 gallons
of oil was spilled into the pacific
ocean in southern california efforts to
undo this damage are gonna uh
uh
no sorry
no i don't want to do anything about
this yeah i don't want to think about
this at all because you see
some news gives me the roots
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist
thousands upon thousands of gallons of
oil in the pacific ocean
that just doesn't exist
some news fills me with joy
some news fills me with this
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this in a
recent instagram post singer shakira
revealed that she was attacked in a park
in barcelona by wild boars now the
thought of this happening to shakira
someone i deeply love no i'm going to
pretend like that news story does not
exist is that a healthy derrick nothing
i do is healthy
that just doesn't exist
some news i take a heart
some news i just dismissed
but some news is just so bad baby i
pretend it doesn't exist like this
several plant-based meat companies have
hit the market recently with new
plant-based fish
alternative seafood is one of the
fastest growing segments of that
industry making
people eat that
now that just doesn't exist
it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist no no no baby
it doesn't exist
that news doesn't exist
[Music]
you